[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
talk about
the space environment in which
business surveillance travel
all takes place it's like from earth's
surface
up to the top of the atmosphere that's
something we haven't talked about
chuck hey that's where we're going today
yes that's right what it's what
i like i like space junk better then
[Laughter]
see you said you said it all fancy i
just like
like i i just like to say space jumps
junk
almost here like quincy jones in the bat
plan
stanford and son in space that'll be
exactly that's right
well i've got i've got one of the
world's if not the
world's expert on this very subject
right here with star talk and i and his
name is more baja
more about welcome to star talk thank
you so much
it's an honor and a pleasure to be here
with all of you yeah so
you're an astro dynamicist and space
environmentalist
that sounds like if no one knew what
that was
you would have to invent it just because
the world needs it
right is that is that a fair way to
describe what you do
yeah absolutely yeah okay that's you
know what though i got to tell you
there that that means that there was a
time when there wasn't such there wasn't
well we didn't need you so this is not a
good thing that you exist because you
know
it's like it's like social media manager
like there was a time that meant that
you had somebody
who you were clearly a person who
socialized with the media quite a bit
and you know you needed somebody to
handle that it didn't mean what it means
now
right right right right it's a bad thing
that we have to have
it's a bad thing that you exist i'm
sorry i've got to say that
no no no i agree with all of you
full-heartedly you know
after after about 1957 with the launch
of sputnik
my my the need for me to exist uh began
to grow
all right so now sputnik well let me
finish with the man's resume
so i forgot i'm sorry i already know
it's impressive
[Laughter]
so i'm ready to talk to him because he's
got some fascinating stuff
so he's a professor and researcher at ut
austin
at the cockrell school of engineering
and so let me just give the list here
because every one of these what could be
like an
entire star talk the non-gravitational
astro astrodynamics i love that
advanced non-linear multi-sensor object
tracking
sounds like the pentagon needs you
prediction
and information fusion what a space
object detection
this man is like okay if we're gonna
have a space war i want him on our side
tell me about it but on top of that
we'll get to it
um in a later segment but i want to put
it up front right here
um eyes on the sky mixed reality
experience that's not with the
engineering department what is that
yeah so interestingly enough we have
some faculty that
are in the fine arts and uh
they've created something called texas
immersive and it's really trying to
combine
digital and physical experience for
storytelling
wow okay so this would this would
increase the impact
of any kind of science that you do
absolutely yeah 110 because uh
one of the things that i've seen is just
going to talk to
scientists it's like the echo chamber
and you know the self-licking ice cream
cone
not so not so useful so i need to be
able to reach
reach people and the the storytelling
with mixed reality seems to be something
that could really help
i love that and the website's eyes on
this
eyes on the sky.org so that's good so
chuck would i
keep interrupting you no i was just
gonna say i just want to be a
self-licking ice cream cone now
because that sounds awesome that just
sounds like the happiest thing in the
world
yeah but i think there's a limit though
i think there's that's part of the
problem here it's like
like the snake eating its tail yeah it's
a point where that doesn't really work
out
the best for the snake or the tail
that's right that's right
so uh we're actually going to turn this
into a cosmic queries
where we've actually solicited uh
questions from our fan base i chuck i
think you have those questions
right i i hope so okay
so give me the other chuck who does that
exactly
where's the stuff that has the question
but before we get there while chuck is
finding his questions um
more about you you wrote something
recently just uh
towards the end of may which seemed to
me to be a kind of a
a self-reflection autobiographical
sort of memoir sort of it's an arc of
life
from your beginnings to where you are
right now
and i just want to ask what compelled
you to write that because it is a highly
unusual story and between you and me
every interesting person i know
and have ever met has had an unusual
background it wasn't just that linear
fact go to college go to grad your
school get through it get the degree get
the degree
and then boom no the most interesting
people are the ones who've lived a
little
and often that living involves
stress trauma failures as well as
achievements so
um what can you tell us about that yeah
look i mean
um i grew up in venezuela and
you know i went to military school for
high school and a lot of uh
trial and tribulation going through that
i enlisted in the u.s military when i
graduated and i wanted to be a fighter
pilot uh
watched plenty of top gun when i was a
teenager so that was like my dream
i never thought that space would have a
place for me
and um and yeah basically as a security
guard
guarding nukes in montana that's when i
started noticing dots going across the
sky that disappeared in the middle of
the sky and i'm like
is it just me seeing this like is this a
ufo like what is this right i just i was
completely ignorant and but just to be
clear
yeah it most definitely was a ufo
because you didn't know what you were
looking at
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was it was
definitely ufo for me right
definitely for others for me others it
would have been an ifo
that night for you it was a ufo okay
absolutely
so yeah so basically uh you know when i
when i was able to figure out that um
these things were human-made objects
reflecting sunlight and going through
earth's shadow
that really that really crystallized
this curiosity for me to want to know
more about that and that that's where my
i think my path
towards astro dynamics and emotional
stuff in space started
chuck you see what happens when you look
up sometimes see what happens
and now about you in philadelphia i
don't know where you've been looking
uh when we look up when i looked up what
i saw was a ceiling
so not quite the same by the way you
have to not only look up you have to be
curious about what you see
that's exactly what moribo was doing
okay so how
uh were you american born in venezuela
not
venezuelan otherwise you couldn't just
join the us military
no that that's uh good for you to notice
that so i was born here in the us in san
francisco
actually my mom's from haiti my father
from sierra leone
uh they got divorced and i was very
young my mom
met this guy from venezuela so we moved
to venezuela when i was seven years old
wow okay and tell me about your your
life
in terms of discipline because to be
a faculty member at a major university
specializing in the fields you do
requires discipline
so so how do you go from
from from my reading your attract
basically no discipline to discipline
because that's that's a if that's a
secret you can let out
i think many people by the way that
should be your new job teaching people
that
talk about getting paid
[Laughter]
nice nice yeah absolutely so
look i am i think
when i was a teenager and kind of having
some moments of self-reflection
and going through some very low points
in my life and
i think that i kind of discovered
i want my life to serve a purpose uh for
humanity for other people
and i think the discipline came as a
function of
my inner commitment to to that inner
clarion call
of thou shalt do something uh that's
useful for humanity
and don't let other people's opinion
become your reality sort of thing
i think that's where that came from okay
so
but that takes a level of maturities
particularly growing up to even realize
that
yeah i mean i um having gone through
military school i think
that was being forced to grow up
faster than a regular teenager would
have
and then doing four years in the
military at a nuclear missile base
in montana that was also
something that instilled some hard
knocks
discipline into and to me as well yeah
if that doesn't i don't know what will
here's the nukes you're on watch
right yeah so yeah it's kind of hard to
um
screw that up and then you can't get out
of it with them
my bad my bad
you eat a sandwich and you sit back on
the control board and bam
you pop the ring yeah that's
my bad for a lot of people yeah that's
right everybody's bad everybody's there
right
so before we get to our q a could you
give me
some sense give us all some sense
of the magnitude of the problem of space
junk
right now yeah so
in 1957 we launched sputnik one
one satellite that uh you know didn't
didn't live
in orbit uh too long but since
1957 we've been launching hundreds
thousands of things
and it turns out that now we track
almost 30 000 individual objects
in you know in orbit around the earth
ranging in size from cell phone all the
way to the space station
these things are in different orbital
highways going at very fast speeds as
you know
and so when two things meet at the same
place
at the same time and the speeds are
quite different bad things happen
and they become smaller pieces and they
those collisions generate more garbage
and that sort of thing so
um and we don't have any sort of space
traffic rules
protocols practices that people say yeah
you know if
i'm gonna head towards you uh and you're
headed towards me we'll both turn left
or do this or there there are no rules
of thumb
uh you know in in earth orbit which
makes things a little bit worse
well you mentioned things smaller the
size of a cell phone but you don't mean
actual cell phones are in space
to you well yeah so actual self to the
best of my knowledge we don't have
actual cell phones uh in in earth orbit
but
it wouldn't be it wouldn't be a surprise
to me
if an astronaut went on a spacewalk and
decided to pop this thing out and you
know
they left it like they've left wrenches
and these sorts of things and
and people just don't talk about it
stuff that fell out of people's pockets
exactly
that's right it also wouldn't um
surprise me if uh if
somebody has my carrier which i won't
disparage publicly
but they actually were just trying to
get some service
and that's how far they had to go to try
and get
a damn signal can you hear me now
[Laughter]
i think that's what they needed to do
for the commercial man is actually like
go up to the space station and see see
how well that worked
yeah actually that's a good
advertisement i'll buy that yeah right
that's the carrier i'm going with well
so i love your expertise let's see
how a fan base uh where they come from
with regard
to your expertise and their curiosity so
chuck what do you have
all right for uh dr moore baja we have
questions that
come from our patreon patrons which is
how we solicit our questions now it used
to be that we gleaned them from the
various
uh iterations that we find ourselves on
the internet but
now if you want you just support us on
patreon.com and uh
and then we'll we'll read your question
here's the deal um
jeff johnson of salt lake city utah says
uh dr jaw can you please give us some
insight into china's recent space
station snafu
were they irresponsible or was there a
really little to no danger to earth's
inhabitants
or did they do it on purpose yeah
this uh is with a rocket booster from
one of the stages
and it just they didn't know where it
was gonna fall and i thought
when you launched something that big you
put little retro rockets or something on
it
and you guide the thing into the that
great toilet bowl of space the pacific
ocean
so what what went wrong here or what was
not in the planning from the beginning
yeah so i think you got it uh as they
say tickety-boo
uh there neil in that the responsible
thing would have been to
outfit this rocket with uh you know
propellant and thrusters to force it in
to
maximize the chance of the thing not
surviving re-entry but
you know when you when you leave it to
mother nature to clean up the mess
uh hard to predict what mother nature is
gonna do sometimes and so
i think that's where the the increased
risk uh is
and you know until china uh actually
puts on these thrusters for
subsequent rocket bodies it's it's a
problem and
and it it's it's really bad news to
make the world uh you know spin up on
you know is the sky actually going to
fall on me today well
so so it sounds like the wild west
aren't we overdue for some rules and
regulations
a treaty that everyone a tr treaty for
what you do with your trash
it's a trash treaty all right all right
everybody gets together here's how you
dispose
of the recyclables the the smelly trash
the the the burnable trash why don't we
have that
yeah so the interesting thing is that we
do have the united nations convention
on liability and damage and it
specifically
states uh that you know
the the parties to to the treaty should
avoid harmful interference i would say
that a big rocket body falling on top of
your head
would constitute harmful interference uh
but the thing is it's so loosely
interpreted that
perhaps china is saying well we don't
necessarily consider that harmful
harmful interference is not
really defined and i think that's the
major issue so
from a sheerly
litigious standpoint
is that a word cheerily i don't know it
is now
serially uh no from a sheer uh
legitimacy of like or pertaining to
sheer sheer
like there you go so they they are i
told you it's a word now
in the chuck dictionary look let me tell
you something there's three dictionaries
all right
you got webster's you got oxford and you
got chuck yeah
there you go so uh but so if if you are
looking technically
by the law they're not irresponsible but
then
if you wanted to attach morals to this
then yes they would be irresponsible
yeah
absolutely right and i think uh you know
most of the world
agrees that this is not behavior that
they want to see
uh carry carry on carried forward and
they should do something responsible
about it just like neil said
uh finding a way to purposely deorbit
this thing so that at least there's some
intent
with how the thing might uh re-enter and
hopefully
you know burn up all right that's the
next question
is it from patreon or is it from you no
it's from me yeah i told you you want to
ask a question you could be better going
join patreon
i just saw it while we were here okay
all right i wouldn't know i go
okay has the united states
ever done this all right we will get to
that after the break
all right yeah so it's one thing to
point your finger if if you know who
he who have cast the first stop no he
who is without sin
cast the first that's the first we will
get back to that when star talk returns
space junk we're back star talk
got special guest maura baja who's a
professor of
was it astrodynamics did i get that
right yeah absolutely
astrodynamics i love it i love it at the
university of texas at austin
and is in their school of engineering
and i have chuck
though before the break chuck asked a
great question and even though he's not
on patreon i let him ask this question
it was here we are pointing our fingers
to china for
dropping one of their boosters who knows
where right
well we know where but they didn't know
where until it hit
so are we without guilt in this
game of lost boosters
no we're not in fact i would say in in
low earth orbit where
you can think of low earth orbit going
from about i don't know
roughly 100 kilometer altitude to about
you know 1200 kilometer altitude
there's probably about 2 000 uh dead
rocket bodies derelict rocket bodies uh
of of the 2000 probably about 1300
belong to
russia uh launched from the soviet uh
union era and all that stuff wow still
there
wow yeah yeah still there and and the
remain out of the remaining 700 i'm
thinking that
uh somewhere about uh 350 of those
are chinese and the rest are american so
so the u.s
has quite a few a hundred dead rocket
bodies
that are kind of like ticking time bombs
and um
oh and none of them have have i have
will have a controlled reentry that's
what you're telling us
that's what i'm telling you okay so
of all the non-controlled re-entries
going forward
based on your statistics half will be
old russia
half of the half that remains is china
and then what remains is going to be us
so they'll
watch that space plus skylab we didn't
have that
seemed like enough people went in and
out of sky lab we should have known
where that would have fallen and we
didn't at the time i was alive
and around and ready for that and i
remembered baskin robbins
the ice cream store said if you get hit
with a skylab part you will get an ice
cream cone that has every one of their
flavors stacked on top of it
wow what a what what a prize right what
a price for being dead yes
yeah yeah yeah so so tell me what was
what happened with skyland america's
first
sky lab laboratory yeah i mean
um as as as you said that thing
re-entered
and um people were pretty freaked out
about that i remember the mere space
station
uh those were that's the one that i
remember was mere
and uh even that was a very you know
scary experience
all right so we are not without guilt so
we just have to it'd be nicer if we
weren't
pretend we were high and mighty uh as we
point our fingers well that kind of
brings up uh
that that brings further to bear the
point that you made about
having international rules actual rules
you know then everybody would have to
follow them yeah you know yeah chuck
give me some more questions
all right here we go this is uh robert
weaver and
he says um hey would it be possible to
use
uh the lagrange point to make a giant
pile of space debris
seems like that would be easier than
bringing it all back to earth
and much more ethical than just flinging
it out into space
also in the future we could use it like
an auto junk yard
and when we want components or metals or
stuff like that
we could just go to that to build in
space instead of recycling
oh wow that's right so so more but tell
us first about lagrange points
yeah so basically these are points in
a three body system where uh
you have some stable and some unstable
points places where
uh this gravitational influence in in
that system
is let's let's say kind of null things
cancel each other out
um but yeah out of the five out of the
five points
out of the five lagrange points uh i
believe two of them
are are stable and the other three are
unstable and so
i would say this we need to find ways of
not
creating orbital landfills so so the
thing is sending
stuff to lagrange point uh while you
might be able and oh by the way
even when you send stuff there it
doesn't mean it just stays there forever
like you know eventually the thing's
gonna drift out just due to
perturbations that are non-gravitational
uh mostly in that sort of stuff plus
as as neil you clearly you know this uh
there's more than just a few bodies
in in in the universe and so eventually
uh
you know the curvature of space-time
will force these things out
uh if they're uncontrolled so it's not a
good answer
and uh uh it's not a viable solution and
we should avoid
uh trying to find the place in space to
just send garbage to
right so uh yeah and and so basically
let me just see if i got this right he's
asking whether or not we could create
a celestial equivalent
of our ocean's great garbage patch
which is where the currents come
together and create a stillness
and then let's do that in space and
let's do this do that in space
i love it so we don't want we don't want
to do that okay so just
let me throw some astrophysics in here
okay the one of the legrands one of the
attractive
lagrange points in the jupiter orbit
the jupiter sun orbit there's a leading
lagrange point and a trailing lagrange
point
if you look there there are asteroids
that have collected there and they're
called the trojan asteroids
and so it's it's fascinating and we knew
to look there because we said
there's a place where all the
gravitational forces cancel out
so there's got to be some anything that
sort of drifts in
won't have a reason to drift out very
quickly or at all
so we actually find these places that
have
our repositories but i like the trash
heap example
uh and i think a samford and son space
in space we should do that for sure
we when if we do do that it should have
the theme song
that goes on without doubt
and by the way every time you drop
something off in that
great uh junkyard in the sky you should
hear
shut up dummy
all right give me some more all right
here we go
chris newbury and chris says
uh hey chuck bet you don't get my last
name correct on the first try oh
man that and that that see
i should read these first uh i'm going
to say new bry
instead of newbury but anyway because
it's uh any wbry
dr tyson just love you and uh love uh
your cosmic queries book um spacex
the idea that put 42 000 satellites into
orbit for optimal internet around the
world
that being said does that put a lot of
junk
into orbit how much does that increase
the risk
of future endeavors uh of this
rock having such a net
surrounding it oh so
let me reshape that slightly so more
about if we have
functioning satellites then they're not
junk but if you have thousands and
thousands of functioning satellites
isn't there still a risk that they could
collide with each other
yes and and so and so i would say this
low earth orbit
is already building itself up to be
this place with these functioning
satellites like you said owned by
different companies
but there isn't uh a space
traffic coordination uh entity right so
so the thing is
people are making decisions about how to
maneuver
and go you know how they want their
satellites to behave
but they're doing that in the absence of
coordinating with other people that are
also making decisions and so that
does increase the risk of things uh
you know bumping into each other in the
night so to speak and it's not and space
isn't just so supremely empty that we
shouldn't worry about it
no because we have very specific orbital
highways where we put these
satellites given the purpose that we
want and right now for instance
uh you know with spacex and the
starlinks which oh by the way
you know out of the nearly 30 000
objects that we track
um about 3 500 our working satellites
and
elon owns about you know 1500 of those
so so it's already quite a bit but uh
wait wait so wait chuck
elon is gonna become skynet oh my god oh
yes look at that and skynet's going to
be
achieve consciousness right and then
throw the robots
off and by the way neil he's your friend
okay i do count him as a friend that's
true
you say that like okay i'm also to blame
just because i know the guy
yeah all right well i thought hold on a
second so i'm not saying that that elon
is at fault for anything what i am
saying is that he owns
most of the working uh satellites uh in
earth orbit
he will continue to own most of them um
as i see now given the fact that he's
got licenses to to launch
and so pretty much if you want to go
beyond 500 kilometer altitude you've got
to coordinate with elon
because because you got to go through
his layer uh of
of starling satellite so the
coordination piece
is really important and that has not
uh become manifest yet so that is an
issue so i got this elon is the next
james bond so
he's double 08. and they say uh
license to launch right
salons license to launch exactly that's
the next thing
oh my god well first of all that sounds
ominous
i know right right right because uh that
guy may be on his way to being the uh
the first uh real super villain
and you heard how quickly morbid back
pedal on on pulling out
his name no let me say something nice
about it before you go to the next topic
i didn't mean he's bad no no no he's
good there's nothing wrong with elon
yeah we all know that jeff bezos is
really the bad one
yeah yeah he's the villain plus he's
bald like like
um you know what he he actually does
make for the perfect
looks like yeah he's going to be the
world's first trillionaire
probably because he'll be the one that
will land on an asteroid and mine it
provided its presence
yeah yeah yeah right all right cool
let's go to uh keep it going
of nish joshi and abnesh says this
hi dr tyson mr nice and dr ja i am
10 years old and i want to be an
astrophysicist
my parents gifted me with the star talk
subscription on my birthday
and this makes me super super excited
damn now we can't potty mouth on the
show no no we go to him
so he says this i read my i read that
space debris is causing the night sky
to be much brighter why does this happen
if it does
and will it not make stargazing that
much more difficult
how can we overcome it wow man
look at this kid man what were you doing
when you were 10. yeah
say one thing it wasn't that it wasn't
that's a good answer more about i don't
know the answer but that is the answer
that's
yeah i was writing letters like dear
santa claus
and people were like you're you still
believe in santa anyway go ahead
so what about night sky observing what's
going on there
yeah so i will say this right i uh i'm
actually working with the astronomy
community
to try to quantify uh the effects and
impacts of
you know these pieces of human stuff
uh you know orbiting the earth and they
do reflect sunlight
so so in a sense it's light pollution
coming from the skies towards the ground
towards large pieces of glass
and yeah when you look at the night sky
if you're in a place dark enough
you're going to see more dots going
across the sky than you did a decade ago
that that
that's happening now and it's not going
to get any better so
i would say to you a 10 year old what's
his name again
abnesh abnesh so i'll say to you abnesh
it's the skies are not going to get less
polluted with time because we're going
to keep on launching satellites
and so the night skies are going to be
changing and
i would love it if you could uh you know
be part of
the group of folks trying to find you
know solutions to the to the problem
so how about this once again we're
admitting we messed up
everything everything and we got we
can't wait till the next generation
get older and fix it that's all yeah the
real sorry avnish
uh yeah you're screwed and we did it
uh basically that's the answer
so sorry abney you're screwed and we and
we are responsible we're responsible
and we're responsible buddy yeah you'll
find us at the in the bahamas
right you'll fix the world by the way
you fixed the world
yeah i know so basically i was just
saying uh what chuck had said is that uh
you know basically i'm trying to
quantify the problem for abnesh's
generation to try to do something about
it i guess
yeah that's great i mean it's you're
really kind of a voice crying in the
wilderness right now my friend
you are indeed the john the baptist of
space junk
because nobody is really paying
attention to this so
it's important work to kind of wake
people up about this issue
you know that's a second religious
reference here yeah no i i really
appreciate that but i know how
john's story ended i was about to say
dude that was
that was great that was very funny okay
all right let me ask you this all right
wait so for the atheists out there uh
john the baptist had his head served
to is it salome who yes
let me ask you this in terms of no no
you're not no i'm on patreon questions
any more questions no
no one per segment okay great here we go
here we go
here's the next one this is from
uh uh semaia
cosmica okay and she says which is the
cosmic seed
are there noticeable effects caused by
space junk in the
scientific astrophotography that
interfere with
ground-based observatories this is kind
of like what up
niece was talking about but more on the
more professional level
when we look up into the sky uh is there
any research
is there any uh discovery that is being
hindered
because of all this junk in space and we
got to do that when we come back
from this next break we'll find out all
the ways that space
junk may be harming the professional
community
even if it's just another interesting
object to watch from the
uh from your backyard so on star talk
stay tuned we're back star talk
and we're talking about space to be
space junk and it's a cosmic queries
just trying to find out how what's going
on and how and why
and we left off chuck with the question
and who is it from teresina is her name
but she calls herself the cosmic seed
the cosmic seed oh very nice so
i i know at least this much morba that
these satellites that reflect sunlight
and you can see them streaking across
the sky
that's primarily in twilight
when you're deep in twilight but once
all of the sky above you
is earth's shadow in space then they
don't
the satellites above you don't see
sunlight and so they don't reflect
so can you think of another cost
to night sky observing if you
can't otherwise see them because they're
deep in earth's shadow
yeah absolutely um so these these
objects in space
uh they're getting they're they're
getting heated up
by by you know the solar solar
radiation and also uh thermal thermal
radiation from
from from the earth if they're
sufficiently low uh gets to where the
satellites
are as well and so when these things go
in a shadow
they're radiating heat and so
from from an infrared uh you know
wavelengths
very important band that we use in
modern astrophysics because not
everything
just gives visible light so yeah we want
to be sensitive to infrared okay go on
yeah so so that's where these things are
now emitters
of of of uh you know infrared
uh radiation that that then pollutes uh
the folks that are doing
ir uh imaging from astronomy wow
observatories that is first fascinating
but
just something you really wouldn't think
about because we we tend to think about
everything in terms of visible light
which
well jordi on star trek would have seen
it right off the bat
right away right yeah because he's got a
full spectrum vision
yes right exactly wow that is so cool
all right so now that it's another
segment i mean
and this this is saying i'm a you're
allowed one question to ask a question
okay
all right so one of the i one of the
reasons why we have all this stuff in
space is because
they forget just the replenishment
of uh outdated uh you know
equipment like still new satellites
they're doing something for us
like so gps or geosynchronous like
they're they're all doing so
communications weather they're all doing
something for us
what if would it help
if there were like a giant
relay station so you wouldn't put
your satellite up into space
you would connect to that satellite
relay station that would serve
as your satellite here on earth
it you know so a geosynchronous
satellite hub a satellite hub thank you
neil so a geosynchronous satellite hub
that would allow you to through like
lasers
to connect anywhere on earth so this
satellite hub is all connected and then
on earth you would connect to that
satellite hub
instead of throwing a piece of equipment
in the sky
i'm making this up as an idea that i
just want to know
could that work and chuck i'm going to
tell you once i tell you a thousand
times
stay off the drugs
that's just a line from from coming to
america
yeah so more about what what what do you
think of that that concept here's
everybody doing independent things well
maybe
right a lot of people want to do the
same thing right
so so i want to say that there's merit
to your idea chuck
absolutely oh man that was the best
blow-off i've received in a long time
he didn't even have to finish he didn't
have to finish he went with
there's merit to your in other words
that is the dumbest crap
i've ever heard would you let the man be
polite he'd be polite
on the show okay no so look i think i
think it's a great idea
if you could get enough people to buy
into it right but uh the thing is
nobody's
nobody's been able to kind of assemble
this sort of
consortium mentality behind doing
something like that everybody wants to
they have their own investors they want
to do their own thing they want
sovereignty
full independence yada yada yada so
people have thought about doing this for
mars actually
ammar is really a mars relay so so
oh my god now you just opened up a whole
new perspective
on space junk for me just now which is
it is emblematic of our
greater problematic disposition here on
earth
which really is emblematic of our
problematic
yes which is
you you had a sentence with those three
words in it
what's wrong with that emblematic of a
problematic
disposition yes okay all right is that
because i'm just trying to follow you
down okay yeah i'm picking up what
you're putting down okay yeah
i mean here's the deal the deal is this
you know we can't we don't really
cooperate
i mean scientists do but other than that
let's be for real
outside of like scientists on this earth
we are effed nobody gets together and
says
hey guys do you got do you want to do
this
just to be clear there are four things
there's science okay
the olympics all right the world cup and
the waging of war
these are the only things that nations
coordinates
i'm going to eliminate one of those
romeo for i think obvious reasons i'm
just saying what you're saying
but you know what i'm saying like that's
so weird like
this problem in the sky from what you
just you know
uh said to us is the fact that we're not
together
we can't get together but we did it with
the space station space internet
except we kicked china out of it for and
then they made their own damn space
station
exactly putting more junk in the sky
well space station is not really junk
though okay so it's not the size of a
football field
yeah that's that's really cool man all
right here we go
all right you got your damn question now
let's go back to patreon
all right this is uh taracina rojas
again who says this
because i like her questions is there a
plan underway to remove this dog on
earth i mean space junk orbiting earth
if so i imagine it must be
really expensive or is there a way to
put together a plan
so that someone could yield a great
profit
ah so she tapping into the real deal
which is
how do we make money off of the space
junk because once you start doing that
everybody will race to remove space junk
yeah that's how you motivate
people so yeah any plans more about it
because it sounds pretty hopeless
well so so in order to like monetize the
whole
uh you know space garbage cleaning thing
a couple things have to happen
first for one i think we need
sustainability metrics like being able
to say
look here's this orbit highway this is
the carrying capacity for the orbit
it's saturated or it's going to be
exceeded
and so in order to get capacity back we
need to remove some stuff right
and um then we could actually hire
somebody
just like uh you know tow truck maybe we
you know when you see a piece of uh
you know some car on the side of the
freeway um you can't just
go into it and pull it off the road
right we have tow trucks that come by
and do that and so
we could have the equivalent you know
orbital tow truck company
that uh you know gets paid to provide
capacity
back to an orbit but without that metric
it doesn't make a whole lot of sense
because there's no rhyme or reason
like what's the benefit of removing this
object versus that one i got it
you create a space tax and that tax
supports
the cleanup to the beautification of the
highways
right oh yeah and that way every launch
there's a little bit of money there
that'll help get your ass back out of
orbit in case you
you you go dead yeah
how about drones is there any way that
we would be able to dispatch drones
that would attach themselves to whatever
i know these things are moving at
incredibly fast speeds
but that would be able to um
safely deorbit them so the drone and
and whatever it is together would the
drone would just drag it down to a place
where
normally drones have propeller blades
which require air no no these are jet
powered jet powered jet pack jones jerk
drones yeah they wouldn't be okay but
and they would only fire
they would be dispatched but they would
only fire
to drag the piece back down to
where the gravity would then take over i
got it
what about what about something like
that well so here's the thing chuck i
mean gravity is
always doing its thing uh so so that so
it's
it's always there the things are always
falling right towards something
uh but yeah i mean basically you know if
if you could have a satellite that
attaches to something to bring it back
down there's several companies that have
proposed something like that i think
astro scale
uh out of japan is one of them oh wow
okay
so chuck you do have having some i'm
getting on your case but these are some
good ideas
okay all right it's not bad all right
okay here we go
uh hey this is gary marmol
and gary marmal says hey
neil and dr ja if light photons
can push and pull a
spacecraft why not bring
the laser for a ride so
he's looking at like solar sails why
can't we do something like a solar sail
on the pieces that are floating up there
well so you have you have an orbiting
laser that you
aim and knock satellites back
down in a controlled way for them to
re-enter and burn up
and cooler and the coolest thing about
it is when the laser fires it goes
[Applause]
the space laser we have the sound
effects already here
you heard it on star talk yeah yeah no
so so look um
certainly there are a couple of groups
of people that are trying to do
something like that from the ground as
uh
kind of like a risk reduction a
demonstration of
the ability of lasers to effectively
remove some
uh objects from orbit people in
australia and canberra are doing that
some folks in germany uh you know
stuttgart and that sort of thing
so people already looking at applying
these lasers at least from the ground to
test that out but yeah here's the
problem chuck is that when you put the
laser in space to do that
um people from a space security
perspective start having concerns
because a threat is something that has
the opportunity capability
and intent to cause harm and so with the
laser you
clearly have an opportunity capability
to harm something then the question is
how do you rule in or out the intent of
this if you can use it to push
uh junk out of the way then maybe you
could do some damage to a working
satellite and how would you know and
that sort of thing so it gets a bit
contentious
interesting and interestingly enough
that you said that about the threat
uh who is to say that you won't use it
to push my working
satellite and disrupt my communications
yeah
yeah right right right or
maybe you did have good intent and then
someone else takes control
that you don't have control over right
so so
it's like someone steals your gun and
then they commit a crime yep
but it was your gun right right so
interesting oh man this is really a
this is quite the perplexing little
problem because it's the wild west
it's the space it really
is that's right oh my god okay all right
well
let's cowboys versus aliens right okay
cowboys versus the
i saw that movie i didn't quite know
what to make of it but
yeah i didn't really like it that much
but you know except for the scenes where
the aliens were
doing um uh probing the humans that was
cool
no the weird thing is they they were
mining earth
right for natural resources way easier
to mine an asteroid
okay why would you come all the way
here it was like earth is not your best
supply
yeah yeah rare ingredients you know it's
like passing by like
30 gas stations just because you know
you
you heard somebody's joey filled up a a
handheld tank
exactly yeah that's crazy okay all right
uh i'm really glad we debunked that
movie it it doesn't deserve anything
there's another one i heard i heard a
radio play of of aliens who came to
earth
sucking up the water because they needed
the hydrogen in the water for them to
survive
and that person probably had only just
learned that
water molecule is h2o right and that's a
they probably just learned that but
didn't learn anything else all right
that
the universe is ninety percent higher
it's hydrogen right right
yeah there's right exactly you don't
have to
yeah let me find an expensive way to get
the hydrogen right
exactly exactly that's so funny yeah
it'd be like creating a big giant tank
that uh allows you to breathe air
right right here on the surface
absolutely all right here we go okay
guys time for just one more question
give it to all right
okay let me give you this one we know vo
letter via letter is the twelve and a
half
that's how that's gonna be your letter
this is via letter brace yourself
yeah we gotta close the show out with 12
year old bialetta uh who is also going
to be an astrophysicist
all right love that at 12 and she knows
this and she says this
i only ever hear space junk described
as being a negative thing so this may be
kind of a weird question
but i'd like to think on the bright side
a little bit
is there any possible upside
to this space jump like even any way to
turn
trash into treasure and then she goes ha
ha
okay actually clearly that's a 12 year
old
joke okay
but go ahead all right worry about what
do you have yeah okay so so to violeta
this is um
very good question in fact one of the
things that i've been proposing
to to nas and other people is let's use
the space garbage as a sensor and what i
mean by that is this right
so uh you know neil had raised this
thing about non-gravitational
astronomics
at the beginning and basically there's
like four things that motivate
motion of stuff in space there's gravity
and then there's everything else
everything else is like radiation uh
electromagnetic type stuff
particles bombarding different surfaces
and so
space environment space weather just
like with earth
earth weather is uh very complex but
the thing is just like we can tell how
global circulation of of water uh
behaves based on following where the
junk goes like chuck had brought up
earlier
we could understand what the space
weather is doing
by following how it influences where the
junk
goes and so we could actually try to
solve the inverse problem
of given the behavior of the junk what's
our interpretation of the space weather
and use that for space weather science
wow call me crazy
so these are these are proxy for like
weather balloons almost or something or
or
weather buoys right absolutely
wow interesting that's but just to be
clear when you say space weather
it's particles from the sun that create
what we could say solar wind
so the space environment has been the
bike
of recent decades has been known as
space weather um that's right and so
wow so they are all just just
corks on the waves and they bob
back and forth wow so i'd like to use
them in that in that way but uh you know
nobody's giving me any funding for that
yet so we'll see well after they hear
this show
except we edit out the chuck parks yeah
by the way now that you said that i take
back everything i said about jeff bezos
i love you jeff i love you
cool well let's we got to end it there
but let me ask so moira what's your
social media presence
yeah so basically if you go to like
flow.page
forward slash morba you'll find all my
stuff there i'm on instagram
twitter morbidjaw and uh you know also
on facebook and everywhere else
and so yeah i'm easy to find okay maura
baja m-o-r-i-b-a
pronounced as it's spelled spelled as
it's pronounced and jaw j-a-h
right and chuck you're on social media
yes sir
at chuck nice comic there you go and i
and i do uh i don't officially follow
you i have you on a list
so oh wow maybe i do follow you do wait
well well you better start i track i
track you i don't know if i officially
follow you but i do track
i know your stuff follow me this is so
disappointing on so many levels
my god i've never been more okay
tonight i will follow you okay thank you
all right chuck i think i already do
follow you though
i follow pee wee herman and not me
are you kidding me nice yeah
thank you i'll i'll get on the bar and
i'll dance with some big shoes maybe
that will change your mind
all right we got to call it chris there
more but thanks for this uh
you know as more things fall out of the
sky can we think of you
yeah absolutely so so here's what i want
people to do right i want people to go
to eyes on the
dot org check it out see what we're
doing make a contribution if you're so
inclined and
let's keep let's keep the the love on on
being environmentalists for the sky
alive and well because you can't love
what you don't know
exactly well you can't love it as deeply
as you ever knew you could
until you have a have some kind of
emotional
psychological relationship uh with the
cause so
it's all it's all good and continued
success
uh down there in austin and i was just
there a few days ago
it became a big city while i was gone i
know right
yeah all right uh so i'm
neil degrasse tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist as always bidding you
to keep looking up